دا من هذه العواجل التي تظهر على الشاشه
وفق اعلانات كتاب القسام المنطقه الجنوبيه
الغربيه من مدينه غزه لا تزال تشهد
مواجهات واشتباكات من المسافه صفر تعود
المناطق الشماليه لقطاع غزه رغم
الانسحابات التي شهدتها المناطق الشماليه
الغ الشماليه الغربيه من انسحابات القوات
الاحتلال خلال الساعات ال 48 الماضيه تعود
المناطق الجنوبيه الغربيه من مدينه غزه
لتكون نقاط اشتباك اذا ما دخلنا الى هذه
المنطقه فنتحدث عن محورين اساسيين محور
انسحابات كما ذكرنا في المنطقه الشماليه
الغربيه من اطراف مخيم الشاطئ والشيخ
رضوان وصولا الى العطاطه وكل المناطق
والاحياء في تلك المنطقه وصولا الى السياج
الفاصل او على الاقل الى المناطق الفارغه
او المناطق المفتوحه بعمق 1 م تقريبا هناك
تتمركز قوات الاحتلال لم يصل احد حتى هذه
اللحظه الى هذه النقاط لنتاكد ان كانت
قوات الاحتلال قد انسحبت فعلا من منطقه
العطاطه او ما زالت خارج السياج الحدودي
دخلت منطقه زكيم ونتفها سراه ام انها في
المناطق داخل قطاع غز ولكن الاخبار
العاجله التي ترد الان من المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وكتاب القسام على وجه التحديد
تتحدث عن مناطق اكثر اشتعالا بعد توغلات
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي خلال الايام القليله الماضيه
تمركزت في المناطق الجنوبيه الغربيه من
مدينه غزه في هذه النقاط او في هذا الشارع
شارع رقم 10 الذي نشاهده على الشاشه في
هذه الدائره تمركزت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي خلال الايام القليله الماضيه
وبدات بتنفيذ عمليات تو غل محدود باتجاه
المناطق الشماليه اي انها اي اننا نتحدث
عن المناطق الجنوبيه الغربيه الشيخ عجلين
وتل الهوا ولكن الان العمق الذي وصلت له
قوات الاحتلال خلال هذه التوغ يمكن القول
بانها تجاوزت حوالي 2 م او اقل بقليل
عندما ندخل الى هذه المنطقه فنحن نتحدث عن
هذه الاماكن التي دخلت اليها قوات
الاحتلال ولا تزال تشهد مواجهات عنيفه وفق
اعلان كتاب القسام القسام قالت قبل قليل
بانها قنصت 15 جنديا اسرائيليا من المسافه
صفر في منطقه الجوازات ودكت او ضربت اليات
عسكريه في منطقه الجامعات منطقه الجوازات
هذه هي منطقه الجوازات وهذه منطقه
الجامعات اي اننا نتحدث عن هذا المربع
الذي يشهد الان اعنف العمليات العسكريه من
المسافه صفر بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه
وقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بالاضافه الى
ورود انباء عن اشتباكات في منطقه السرايا
ولكن شاهدنا قبل قليل مراسلنا في منطقه
السرايه اي ان منطقه السرايا على الاقل
يمكن القول بانها اخف حده من الاشتباكات
ولكن هذا المربع الذي نتحدث عنه ونتحدث عن
مسافه لا تتجاوز كيلو متر تقريبا في
تقريبا اقل من كيلومتر اي اننا نتحدث عن 1
م مربع الان خلال الساعات العشره الماضيه
يشهد اعنف الاشتباكات امتدادا من شارع
الصناعه هذا هو شارع الصناعه مع تقاطع
شارع الثلاثيني بهذا الشكل مع تقاطع شارع
عمر المختار بهذا الشكل هذه المنطقه التي
نتحدث عنها والتي تشهد اع في الاشتباكات
هذه النقطه الدائره الاولى منطقه الجوازات
الدائره الثانيه منطقه الجامعات جامعه
الازهر جامعه الاقصى والجامعه الاسلاميه
في هذه المنطقه هاتان المنطقتان تشهدان
الان اعنف الاشتباكات بين قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي والمقاومه المقاومه اكدت بانها
قنصت 15 جنديا في هذه المنطقه ولكن هذه
الاشتباكات ليست الوحيده ا ان المنطقه
الجنوبيه من قطاع غزه لا تزال تشهد
اشتباكات عنيفه وتحديدا المناطق الغربيه
من مدينه خانيونس او من محافظه خانيونس
كنا نعلم في الاسابيع القليله الماضيه ان
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تو غلت باتجاه
خانيونس من الجهه الشرقيه والشماليه
الشرقيه والجنوبيه الشرقيه ولكنها خلال
الايام القليله الماضيه ركزت عملياتها
العسكريه في المنطقه الغربيه وتحديدا
منطقه المخيم وما حول المخيم عندما نتحدث
عن المخيم مخيم خان يونس نتحدث عن اقصى
المناطق الغربيه من مدينه خانيونس بين
مدينه خانيونس وبين البحر هناك مخيم
خانيونس في تلك المنطقه تشهد الاشتباكات
العنيفه رغم بعض الانسحابات قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي نفذت مجموعه من الانسحابات في
هذه المنطقه المنطقه الغير غربيه ذهبت
باتجاه الشمال من منطقه المخيم ذهبت
باتجاه الشمال وتركز على منطقه الامل حي
الامل وما حوله وهذه الاحياء الجديده في
هذه المنطقه اذا كنا نشاهدها بصوره اقرب
فنشاهد انها احياء جديده فيها الحي
الياباني والحي الهولندي ومجموعه من
الاحياء ولكن هنا في هذه المنطقه الدائره
الكبيره تشهد الاشتباكات العنيفه بين
المقاومه الفلسطينيه بعد ان نفذت لقوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الانسحاب من منطقه
المخيم وشاهدنا ورصدنا مع مراسلينا حجم
الدمار الكبير الذي خلفه الاحتلال في
منطقه مخيم خانيونس ولكنه لم يستطع باي
حال من الاحوال التوغل في هذه المنطقه او
هذا المربع الذي يشمل مستشفيي ناصر والامل
الذان لا يبعدان عن بعضهما البعض الا
مسافه لا تتجاوز 500 متر في هذه المنطقه
قلب مدينه خان يونس لم تتوغل قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي حتى هذه اللحظات